Two days after the catastrophic collapse of
a critical dam in southern Ukraine, rescue
efforts continue.
With dramatic scenes like this, taking place
as the scope of the devastation becomes increasingly
clear, as each hour passes.
But it is not rising waters posing a challenge
to residents in kherson, homelessness, the
threat of disease and floating land mines
are all adding to the increased safety risk,
in addition to the fighting.
Ukrainian officials are accusing Russian forces
of shelling evacuation areas, injuring nine
civilians, one by the way, critically.
Volodymyr zelenskyy visited earlier and called
for clear and quick global response to the
disaster.
In the meantime, they tell CNN Ukraine forces
are being met with stiff resistance as they
tried to break through Russian lines in the
eastern part of the country.
CNN's Sam kiley joins us now
[12:02:18 PM]
CNN's Sam kiley joins us now from Kyiv.
The fact that Ukrainian soldiers are being
met with stiff resistance, what does that
tell us about the pending counteroffensive,
and how hard it will be?
>> I don't think it tells us anything at all,
Zain.
Obviously, they will be met with stiff resistance.
This is a war.
I think the important news is twofold.
First of all, that there have been these probing
attacks along the front line in zaporizhzhia,
which have involved Ukrainian troops, they
have been using some of the nato supplied
equipment.
This was always going to be an extremely well
defended frontline, and a lot of the evidence,
particularly on social media is that the Ukrainian
troops are meeting resistance in that area.
At the same time, though, they are now reporting
some significant advances, over three and
a half kilometers, albeit down a fairly narrow
corridor, south of the city of bakhmut, those
advances being reported by Ukraine's third
assault brigade.
[12:03:21 PM]
This is what some of it looked like.
>> Ukraine's third assault brigade isn't action
in bakhmut.
[Sound of gunfire] And they claim they are
making advances around the city, but their
attack is dependent on soviet-era weapons.
[Sound of artillery] Modern equipment from
the usa and nato is apparently being held
in reserve for a Ukrainian offensive.
>> Do you have a name for your grad?
Is a good enough for this fight?
[Speaking non-english]
>> Ukraine gets no help at all with aircraft.
Not so far.
This soviet-era helicopter is ancient.
But in combat almost every day.
Flying dangerously low to avoid missiles and
Russian jet hunter killers.
[Speaking non-english]
[12:04:23 PM]
>> These aircraft fly more as fighting intensifies
in a relentless cycle of war.
Ukraine has not added rage, at what it is
calling a Russian eco-side.
This part of kherson has suffered Russian
bombardment for months.
Now, near total destruction from upriver.
Russia's widely blamed for the collapse of
the dam at nova kakhovka, which has been under
its control since March last year.
Civilians who survived the Russian occupation
of the town and an offensive to free it are
now facing down a new horror.
Thousands have no drinking water.
Here, a drone delivers help, an adaptation
of a system, originally designed not to save
lives, but to take it.
>> Now Zain, amidst all of this
[12:05:27 PM]
>> Now Zain, amidst all of this of course
there is and speculation about whether or
not Ukraine has begun its planned counteroffensive.
I think the efforts where they have seen resistance
near zaporizhzhia, these attacks we have seen
coming south from bakhmut and indeed the raids
into Russia itself, they are all part of the
ongoing shaping operations.
Earlier on today, I sent a text message to
Mr. Reznikov, the defense minister here saying,
has your offense started?
He sent back a message saying, no, our counteroffensive
started on the 20 for the
Ukrainian officials reporting that at least
nine people have been injured as Russian forces
target evacuations in kherson, both Moscow
and Kyiv accuse each other of shelling as
rescuers rushed to help people escape the
flooding from a dam collapsed earlier this
week.
One apparent attack erupting as Ukraine's
chief rabbi was talking about the evacuation
efforts.
>> And --
[sound of artillery]
>> The rabbi hitting the ground to take cover.
Soldiers are heard yelling to get down as
they move to a safer spot.
Ukrainian president volodymyr zelenskyy visiting
the region, and meeting with a workers today.
[11:08:43 AM]
today.
In the meantime, Kremlin officials say Russian
forces have repelled for Ukrainian attacks
in the southern zaporizhzhia area.
CNN cannot independently verify those claims.
In the meantime, two U.S. Senior officials
tell CNN that Ukrainian forces are taking
significant losses on both sides of this.
Ukraine's deputy defense minister reporting
battle games are on the eastern city of bakhmut.
They say to the epicenter of hostilities,
CNN has learned the Russians have put up stiff
resistance, with mine fields that have taken
a heavy toll on Ukrainian armored vehicles.
CNN's Sam kiley has more.
>> Ukraine's third assault brigade isn't action
in bakhmut, they claim their making advances
around the city.
But the attack is dependent on soviet-era
weapons.
[11:09:44 AM]
soviet-era weapons.
Modern equipment from the usa and nato is
apparently being held in reserve for a Ukrainian
offensive.
>> Do you have a name for it?
Is a good enough for this fight?
>> Ukraine gets no hope at all with aircraft,
not so far.
This soviet-era helicopter is ancient.
But in combat almost every day.
Flying dangerously low to avoid missiles and
Russian jet hunter killers.
[Speaking non-english]
>>
These aircraft will fly more as fighting intensifies.
In a relentless cycle of war.
Ukraine has now got added range
[11:10:47 AM]
Ukraine has now got added range in what it
is calling a Russian eco side.
This side of kherson has suffered Russian
bombardment across the river for months.
Now, near total destruction from up river.
Russia's widely blamed for the collapse of
the dam at nova kakhovka which has been under
its control since last year.
Civilians who survived the Russian occupation
of their town and an offensive to free it
are now facing down a new horror.
Thousands have no drinking water.
Here, a drone delivers help, an adaptation
of a system originally designed not to save
life, but to take it.
Sam kiley, CNN, in eastern Ukraine.
>> With all of this, and despite some sanctions,
Russia's trade with China, just saw a huge
increase.
According to Chinese customs being released,
trade between the two countries in the first
[11:11:47 AM]
the two countries in the first five months
of the year, jumped more than 40% compared
to last year, hitting that big number, 94
billion dollars.
China's relationship of course with Russia
has been an economic lifeline for Moscow under
heavy sanctions.
But the Asian powerhouse trades with several
other countries,